Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Pfeifender Wind,
bedrohliche Klänge *
* Schlottern *
Ganz schreckliches Wetter.
Es wurde dunkel und kälter.
Wir haben uns nicht mehr bewegt.
Der Wind wehte in einer Stärke ...
... extrem.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
(Mann auf Englisch)
Diese Böen waren unbeschreiblich.
Du konntest nicht stehen.
Sie haben uns einfach umgeworfen.
(Mann auf Italienisch)
Der Atem erzeugte Eisbärte,
die 30 cm lang waren.
Man konnte sie ab und zu abbrechen.
Es war wie in einem Zombiefilm.
Für die nächsten 8 Std.
muss ich diese Bewegung machen.
Nichts anderes.
Ich muss am Leben bleiben.
Mein Verstand war schon weg.
Als ich die Visionen hatte,
war ich bereits in Trance.
Irgendwann dachte ich dann schon:
"Oh Gott, sind jetzt alle tot?"
Am 29. April 2018 sterben sieben
Menschen aus einer 10er-Gruppe
auf der Haute Route,
der legendären Skitour
zwischen Chamonix und Zermatt.
Darunter auch der Bergführer.
Sie sind nur gerade 550 m
von der rettenden Hütte entfernt,
der Cabane des Vignettes.
Auch die Bergretter werden
vom Ausmass des Dramas überrascht.
(Mann auf Französisch)
Wir kommen zur Cabane des Vignettes,
fliegen über den Pass
und sehen auf der Höhe der Hütte
eine Person im Schnee liegen
und auf der Felskuppe eine Person,
die mit Armbewegungen
auf sich aufmerksam macht.
Aiuto!
Hätte ich nur gewusst,
dass dort draussen Menschen sind Ð
wir hätten versucht, sie zu retten.
Aber wir wussten es nicht.
Ich fühle mich
sehr schlecht deswegen.
Drei Menschen aus der Gruppe
haben überlebt.
Zum ersten Mal
sprechen sie über das Unglück.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Tommaso Piccioli,
er ist in Rimini geboren.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass man auf Glück hoffen kann,
wenn man sich
in eine solche Situation begibt.
Man kann auch nicht
darauf vertrauen.
Man ist selber schuld.
Es ist einfach dumm,
in eine solche Situation zu kommen.
Der Typ war dumm und
wir waren so dumm, ihm zu folgen.
Überlebt hat auch Luciano Cattori,
aus Locarno.
Ich kann nicht sagen, ob er
einen Fehler gemacht hat oder nicht.
Es war einfach Pech.
Praktisch alles lief gegen ihn.
Sein GPS funktionierte nicht, er
konnte sein Telefon nicht benutzen.
Er konnte die Karte
nicht mehr lesen,
weil er nicht mehr sehen konnte.
Was sollte er tun?
Julia Hruska versucht zu verstehen,
warum die Bergtour
so kurz vor der rettenden Hütte
für sieben ihrer Gruppe
mit dem Tod enden musste.
Warum ist er so weit gegangen?
Warum sind wir nicht umgedreht?
Warum hat er das Satellitentelefon
nicht früher benutzt?
Warum haben wir
nicht früher Hilfe geholt?
Am Ende denke ich, dass er
immer noch hoffte, anzukommen,
trotz des Unwetters
und der grossen Gruppe.
War es Pech?
War es menschliches Versagen?
Oder war es Leichtsinn?
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Dieser Film ist eine Rekonstruktion
der Ereignisse des 29. April 2018,
mithilfe von Überlebenden,
Rettern, Beteiligten
und nachgestellten Szenen.
Sie beginnt bei Julia Hruska,
welche die Tour
auch fotografisch dokumentierte.
Das ist das erste Foto,
vom Treffen auf dem Parkplatz.
Es war das Kennenlernen.
Alle waren entspannt
und haben sich nett begrüsst.
Die Gruppe
fährt mit dem Bus nach Chamonix.
Gebucht haben sie die Tour
beim italienischen Bergführer
Mario Castiglioni,
der mit seiner Ehefrau Kalina eine
eigene Agentur in Chiasso betreibt.
Für Julia
ist Mario ein alter Bekannter.
Mario kannte ich damals
seit acht oder neun Jahren.
Wir waren z.B. zusammen in Alaska,
Heliskiing,
wir waren zusammen in Usbekistan.
Wir haben auch hier in den Alpen
viel zusammen gemacht.
Wir waren im Winter
ständig zusammen unterwegs.
Und auch Luciano kennt Mario:
Mario war ein Freund.
Das kann ich wirklich sagen.
Wir waren über zehn Jahre
zusammen unterwegs.
Tommaso ist mit seiner
guten Freundin Betty dabei.
Sie hat die Tour organsiert.
Ich wusste absolut nichts über ihn.
Ausser, dass er berühmt war.
Ein paar Freunde aus Milano
kannten ihn.
Hatte er einen guten Ruf?
Ja, er schien bei allen
einen guten Ruf zu haben.
Begleitet werden sie von einem
befreundeten Ehepaar aus Bozen
sowie zwei weiteren Teilnehmern
aus Como und Parma.
Sie alle haben bei Marios Agentur
1'500 Fr. bezahlt,
Übernachtungen mit Halbpension
in den Hütten inbegriffen,
und v.a. für Marios Dienste
als Bergführer,
der sie in sechs Tagen sicher von
Chamonix nach Zermatt bringen soll.
Wir waren wie Freunde.
Wir hatten die gleiche Leidenschaft.
Die Haute Route, die Skitour
durch die höchsten Berge der Alpen,
ist ein Mythos und lockt Tourengänger
aus der ganzen Welt an.
Sie verbindet Chamonix im Westen
und Zermatt mit seinem Wahrzeichen,
dem Matterhorn, im Osten.
Eine anspruchsvolle Tour,
ein Traum für trainierte Berggänger.
Ich habe mein Leben lang
darüber nachgedacht.
Seit ich Skitouren mache,
war es mein höchstes Ziel.
Und in dem Jahr hatten wir Zeit,
und Betty hatte ihr Sabbatical.
(Luciano)
Vor etwa 45 oder sogar 50 Jahren
bin ich die Haute Route mit der
damaligen Ausrüstung gefahren:
mit schweren Ski
und ganz harten Schuhen.
Da dachte ich mir:
"Jetzt will ich es noch einmal
mit moderner Ausrüstung versuchen."
Und so beschloss ich mit Mario,
diese Haute Route zu versuchen.
E allora dico:
"Questa volta faccio l'Haute Route."
Es war ein schöner Winter,
auch mit viel Schnee.
Und so zum Ende der Saison
gab es dann eben seine Haute Route,
seine Gruppe, seine Tour,
und es war dann doch auch noch
für mich möglich, mitzumachen.
Es gab einen Platz und ich dachte:
"Wenn nicht jetzt, wann dann?"
Start der Tour ist in Chamonix
und führt sie am ersten Tag über
Argentière zum Refuge Albert 1er.
Dann geht es weiter über Verbier
hoch zur Cabane du Mont Fort.
Von dort in die Cabane des Dix,
danach ins Rifugio Nacamuli
und in die Cabane de Bertol.
Die Ankunft
ist am sechsten Tag in Zermatt.
7'000 Höhenmeter, 80 km,
meistens auf 3'000 m Höhe,
inmitten der Viertausender
warten auf die Gruppe.
(Julia) In Chamonix haben wir
erst einmal ins Hotel eingecheckt
und unsere Sachen gerichtet.
Dann machte Mario ein Briefing,
was ich sehr gut fand.
Das war nicht immer üblich
bei uns als Gruppe,
die wir uns eben kannten.
Aber da hat er das
schon auch ernst genommen
und hat noch einmal
seine Sachen vorgestellt:
seinen Rucksack, seine Ausrüstung,
ich glaube sogar seine Ski.
(Luciano) Mario
hatte das Satellitentelefon dabei.
Er hatte immer zwei Telefone
und alle Karten.
Und dann die Seile,
die zur Sicherung der Gruppe
verwendet wurden.
The only thing that ...
Was mich etwas erstaunt hat, war,
dass niemand einen Helm dabei hatte,
ausser Luciano.
Nicht einmal er hatte einen Helm.
Und ich bin mir fast sicher,
dass ich nur deshalb noch hier bin.
Nach der Tragödie eröffnet
die Staatsanwaltschaft Wallis
eine Untersuchung, die bestätigt,
dass sämtliche Teilnehmenden
gut ausgerüstet waren
und der Bergführer Mario
ein Seil, Satellitentelefon,
eine GPS-Armbanduhr
und ein GPS-Telefon dabei hatte.
Auch Tommaso Piccioli
trug ein GPS mit sich.
Wie sich später herausstellt,
war die Gruppe für eine Tour unter
guten Wetterbedingungen gerüstet,
jedoch nicht
für die Schlechtwetterfront,
die zu dem Zeitpunkt
bereits angekündigt war.
(Julia) Schon am ersten Tag
gab es ein volles Programm.
Man fuhr Ski, man querte,
man musste aufsteigen,
auch in steilerem Gelände.
Es war ein guter Einstieg,
vielleicht auch ein guter Test,
wie die Gruppe funktioniert,
wer stärker ist, schwächer ist
und wer welche Erfahrung hat.
Es war fantastisch:
Das Wetter war unglaublich schön,
dann dieses riesige Eisfeld.
Mario wird in den nächsten Tagen
für acht Gäste verantwortlich sein.
Stop!
Das ist viel.
Normalerweise kümmern sich
auf der Haute Route zwei Bergführer
um eine Gruppe dieser Grösse.
Ich wusste, wir waren zu viele.
Ein erfahrener Alpinist sagte mir:
"Du bist verrückt,
mit zehn Leuten und nur einem Führer
auf eine solche Tour zu gehen."
Es waren auf relativ engem Raum
viele Leute,
die sich die Ski abschnallen und
am Rucksack befestigen mussten ...
Es war einfach auch Arbeit -
für uns, aber auch für Mario,
Es war viel Organisation.
Und mit einer so grossen Gruppe
verliert man natürlich bei solchen
Stellen einfach auch viel Zeit.
Mario verlässt sich
wie immer bei solchen Touren
auf die Hilfe seine Frau Kalina.
Sie bildet jeweils
den Schluss der Gruppe.
Kalina ist zertifizierte Wander-
und Tourenleiterin sowie Skilehrerin,
ausgebildet in Bulgarien.
Mit viel Erfahrung im Hochgebirge
und auf Hochtouren,
aber sie ist keine Bergführerin.
(Julia)
Na ja, ein eingespieltes Team.
Es gab wenig Diskussion,
wer was macht.
Kalina war für mich
eine Bergführerin.
Sie war sehr gut.
Sie war zugänglicher als Mario.
Sie war wirklich nett.
Im Gegensatz zu ihm
war sie herzlich.
Das war der Hauptunterschied.
Kalina und Mario lernten sich
vor zehn Jahren in Bulgarien kennen
und waren danach bald als Paar
auf Bergen in der ganzen Welt
gemeinsam unterwegs,
bevor sie heirateten.
An Mario habe ich geschätzt,
dass er ein sehr zuverlässiger,
vernünftiger Typ war -
Bergführer, aber auch im Privaten.
Wir waren befreundet.
Er wusste, was er tat.
Er hatte aber auch
eine gewisse Lässigkeit.
Ich weiss nicht, ob es auch
daran lag, dass er Italiener war.
Eine Lässigkeit
auch in der Organisation.
Es musste nicht alles perfekt sein.
Wenn etwas nicht funktionierte,
dann war das halt so.
Der 59-jährige Mario aus Como
war ein erfahrener Bergführer.
Er hatte sich auch einen Namen
als Expeditionsbergsteiger gemacht,
der u.a. drei Achttausender
im Himalaya bezwungen hatte
und mit seiner Agentur Expeditionen
auf allen Kontinenten anbot.
Mario war körperlich sehr stark.
Wenn es nötig war,
in Momenten von Stress,
kam sein starker Charakter
zum Vorschein.
Er war stark und ruhig.
Das war sein Charakter.
Mario hatte lange in Chamonix gelebt
und kannte die Alpen
und die Haute Route,
ob von Skitouren
oder vom Helisikifahren.
Für ihn markierte die Haute Route
im Frühling oft den Abschluss
einer langen Wintersaison.
So auch dieses Mal,
wo er direkt nach der Tour von Gästen
im Süden Sardiniens erwartet wurde.
Er war ein Mensch,
der mit seiner Erfahrung
Ruhe ausstrahlte.
Aber er hielt sich
immer etwas abseits der Gruppe.
Es ist wahr -
jetzt wo ich darüber nachdenke,
war Mario nicht sehr gesprächig.
Ihn interessierte v.a.,
dass alles funktioniert.
Die Gruppe
ist seit zwei Tagen unterwegs,
als sie sich auf die lange,
achtstündige Etappe
zur Cabane des Dix aufmacht.
Es ist der Tag
vor dem grossen Unglück.
Sie kommen gut voran, haben sie doch
alle eine gewisse Skitourenerfahrung.
Bergsteigerisch gesehen
waren sie nicht sehr erfahren.
Es waren normale Leute,
die Touren machten
und dem Bergführer folgten.
Das Niveau variierte zwischen denen,
die mehr
und denen,
die weniger unterwegs waren.
Man merkte schon,
dass Gabriella sicherlich
das schwächste Glied der Gruppe war.
Sie hatte teils
auch Probleme mit den Füssen.
Sie zog sich bei längeren Pausen
die Skischuhe aus.
Ich denke, das ist nicht ideal,
wenn man mehrere Tage unterwegs ist.
Gegen Nachmittag zeigt sich aus Süden
die angekündigte Schlechtwetterfont:
eine typische Föhnlage.
Ich dachte: "Schauen wir mal,
wie schlimm das Wetter wird,
dann entscheiden wir."
"Wir haben ja
einen erfahrenen Führer,
wir brauchen uns also
keine Sorgen zu machen."
Die Cabane des Dix auf 2'928 m
ist eine der beliebtesten Hütten
auf der Haute Route
und bietet Platz
für bis zu 125 Personen.
Sie ist auch an diesem Tag
gut ausgebucht.
Es ist eine moderne Hütte
mit fliessendem Wasser,
berühmt für eine der grössten
Bierkollektionen in den Alpen.
Gegen 16 Uhr trifft die Gruppe
von Mario in der Cabane des Dix ein.
* Stimmengewirr *
Bereits hier ist Steve House,
amerikanischer Bergführer,
mit zwei Gästen
sowie zwei befreundete Ehepaare
aus Frankreich.
Steve House ist mit seinen Gästen
gegen 12 Uhr angekommen.
Er hat in der Hütte als erstes
das Wetter für den morgigen Tag
kontrolliert und ist alarmiert.
Die Wetterprognose
sprach nicht einfach
von einem kleinen Sturm,
sondern von superstarken Windböen.
Ich erinnere mich nicht mehr an
die Details, aber es war nicht so,
dass etwas schlechtes, unangenehmes
Wetter vorausgesagt war.
Es sah so aus,
als ob es nicht zu überleben sei.
Das war die Wetterprognose.
* Unverständliche Szene *
Steve House
ist einer der weltbesten Alpinisten.
Als Bergführer stand die Haute Route
nie auf seiner Liste.
Normalerweise
sucht er Touren abseits der Masse.
Aber zwei seiner Stammgäste
wollten sich diesen Traum erfüllen.
Bereits im Aufstieg am Morgen
erkennt Steve House
die Wolkenfront aus Süden -
die Sturmfront,
die er seit Tagen beobachtet hat.
(Steve House) Wir erreichten
an diesem Tag die Cabane des Dix
relativ früh, vor 12 Uhr.
Wir hatten einen Lunch
und meine Gäste legten sich hin.
Ich bin dann mit den Ski
alleine hoch zur Pigne d'Arolla,
dem Sattel, vom dem man dann zur
Cabane des Vignettes runterfährt.
Den Abschnitt
hatte ich noch nie gemacht.
So steigt er die rund 800 Höhenmeter,
den ersten Teil der morgigen Route,
von der Cabane des Dix
bis in den Sattel der Pigne d'Arolla
auf 3'680 m auf
und legt einen GPS-Track.
Er speichert die Route
mit Punkten und Daten auf seinem GPS.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt sah man,
dass der angekündigte Sturm
tatsächlich aufziehen würde.
Ich brauchte also einen perfekten
GPS-Track, dem ich folgen konnte,
weil es morgen
wirklich schwierig werden könnte.
Ich tat mich zudem
mit Simon Duverney zusammen,
einem befreundeten Bergführer,
der zwei Wochen zuvor von der Pigne
d'Arolla zur Cabane des Vignettes
runtergefahren war, und er hatte
diesen GPS-Track auf seinem Handy.
So war auch
der zweite Teil der Strecke,
von der Pigne d'Arolla
bis zur Cabane des Vignettes,
mit GPS-Daten abgesichert.
Dieselbe Route planen morgen auch die
beiden Ehepaare Barcan und Reymond.
Sie sind eng befreundet
und unternehmen seit Jahren
gemeinsame Touren in den Bergen,
ohne Bergführer.
Wir nehmen nie einen Bergführer.
* Sie lachen. *
Wir kennen uns ganz gut aus
in den Bergen.
Wir machen das ja schon
seit unserer Jugend.
Bei der Haute Route
hatten wir mit unserer Erfahrung,
den topografischen Materialien
und den Karten nie das Bedürfnis,
dass wir einen Führer brauchen.
Die Ehepaare stammen aus Tignes.
Philippe und Thierry
sind zertifizierte Ski-
und Schneesportlehrer.
Zudem gehört Philippe
dem Bergrettungsteam an.
Philippe und Thierry teilen sich
die Verantwortung für die Tour
und verlassen sich
auch auf der Haute Route
nur auf Karte und Kompass.
Wir wussten, dass es vor dem
Wettereinbruch unter Föhneinfluss
ein Wetterfenster gibt,
und das wollten wir nutzen.
Gemäss Prognose würde das Wetter
bis 14 Uhr stabil bleiben
und sich erst danach verschlechtern.
Bis dann planten wir,
in der Cabane des Vignettes zu sein.
Die einzige Informationsquelle
für das Wetter in der Hütte
ist ein iPad.
Der WLAN-Empfang ist schlecht.
(Tommaso)
Ich schaute mir auf dem iPad an,
was sich da zusammenbraute.
Non promette bene.
Und ich traf diesen
französischen Bergführer, der sagte,
er würde bei dem Wetter
nicht aufbrechen.
Er sagte: "Nicht bei dem Wetter."
"Es gibt einen schlimmen Sturm.
Du musst vorsichtig sein."
Ich ging zurück zum Tisch,
um dies Castiglioni
und den anderen mitzuteilen.
Mario, arriva maltempo.
Auch Mario sieht die Sturmfront,
die morgen hereinbrechen soll.
Zu erwarten sind Schneefall
und Sturmböen von über 100 km/h.,
aber erst gegen 14 Uhr.
Die Nullgradgrenze
sinkt von 3'000 m auf 2'000 m.
Das Hauptproblem am Abend war,
festzulegen,
was am nächsten Tag zu tun ist.
Mario beriet sich auch
mit den anderen Bergführern,
denn wir waren sieben
oder acht Gruppen in der Hütte.
(Tommaso) Er sagte,
wir würden morgen früh entscheiden.
Andrà tutto bene.
Wir sprachen schon darüber, was man
am nächsten Tag machen kann -
im Sinne von: Was schaffen wir
von unserer Haute Route?
Aber auch darüber,
was wir machen können,
wenn wir
unsere Etappe nicht schaffen.
Was gibt es für Alternativen?
Mario hat nicht gesagt,
wir machen das oder das -
wollte er nicht, konnte er nicht ...
Ich denke, wir wollten alle
erst mal das Wetter abwarten,
weil es natürlich
schon der Wunsch war, durchzugehen,
wie es geplant war
und auch in Zermatt anzukommen.
Je nach Wetterentwicklung
stehen drei Varianten zur Auswahl.
Variante 1: wie vorgesehen
in das Rifugio Nacamuli.
Variante 2: in die Cabane des
Vignettes, die 2,5 Std. kürzer ist.
Und mit Variante 3
lässt sich Mario die Option offen,
die Tour unter der Serpentine
abzubrechen
und nach Arolla abzufahren.
Obwohl Steve House alle Vorkehrungen
für den Sturm getroffen hat,
informiert er seine Gäste
über mögliche Varianten,
denn ihre Sicherheit und ihr Wohl
stehen für ihn über allem.
Es ist mir wichtig, darauf
hinzuweisen, dass ich die Situation
auch meinen Gästen
so klar wie möglich dargelegt habe.
Ich habe sie gefragt:
"Was möchtet ihr?
Seid ihr auf ein Abenteuer aus?"
"Es ist ein grosses Risiko,
aber machbar."
"Oder wollt ihr nach Arolla runter?"
"Auch eine schöne Tour,
die auch Spass macht,
aber es ist
die vorsichtige Variante."
Und sie wollten es riskieren ...
... zur Vignettes
über die Pigne d'Arolla.
(Alle) Salute!
Mario hingegen
trifft keine Entscheidung.
Er lässt seine Gäste im Ungewissen.
Die Leute waren
ein bisschen verschlossener,
ein bisschen müder als sonst,
vielleicht,
weil die Vorhersage nicht gut war.
Ich spürte,
dass sie sich Sorgen machten,
auch wenn niemand etwas sagte.
Sie waren sehr ruhig.
Auch Betty.
Wenn es Probleme gab,
war Tommaso der Offenste.
Er stellte die meisten Fragen.
Während Gabriella und ihr Mann,
Francesca und auch Betty
eher ruhig waren.
Sie folgten.
Sie vertrauten dem Bergführer.
* Stimmengewirr *
Alle haben etwas mehr gegessen
als sonst, weil wir hungrig waren.
Tommaso ass
drei oder vier Teller Suppe.
(Tommaso)
Ich habe viel gegessen,
jemand hat das sogar bemerkt.
Ich sagte:
"In den Bergen isst man besser viel.
Man weiss nie, was noch passiert."
Buona notte.
- Buona notte.
Was an dem Abend nie
zur Debatte steht, ist die Option,
nicht aufzubrechen und den Sturm
in der Hütte abzuwarten.
Das wäre im Nachhinein
die sicherste Variante gewesen.
Soweit ich mich erinnere,
gab es niemanden, der sagte:
"Morgen bleibe ich."
Oder: "Ich gehe zurück."
Oder: "Ich komme nicht mit."
Alle wollten die Haute Route
in Zermatt beenden.
* Spannungserzeugende Klänge *
* Sanfte Klänge *
Für Tommaso ist die Geschichte
nicht abgeschlossen.
Er kehrt drei Jahre später
mit einem Bergführer zurück
zur Cabane des Dix -
dahin, wo das Unglück
seinen Anfang nahm.
This is the serpantine.
- Ah, that's right.
Because that's the Pigne?
- The Pigne is on the left.
Ah, okay.
- And the serpatine.
I see. I know where it is then.
- And we go over there.
And the Dix is right there.
- Right up.
Er will den letzten Teil der Tour
noch einmal bei schönem Wetter
absolvieren und versuchen,
Antworten auf Fragen finden,
die ihm keine Ruhe lassen.
Er, der bereits damals Mario nicht
vertraut, hadert immer noch damit,
dass er trotz seiner Zweifel
nicht interveniert hat.
Wie geht es dir heute,
dass du damals nicht reagiert hast?
Ah, well ...
Offensichtlich schlecht natürlich.
Betty wäre noch hier.
Was soll ich sagen ...
Aber ich konnte
in meiner Position nichts tun.
Für mich ist es eine Lehre,
genau das zu tun,
was man im Kopf hat.
Es sei denn, man ist sich zu 100 %
sicher, in guten Händen zu sein.
Würdest du heute etwas anders machen?
Natürlich. Ich würde einfach sagen:
"Ich komme nicht mit."
Der Tag des Unglücks.
(Julia)
Und dann eben das Wetter ...
Aber das war der Morgen.
Es war nicht ganz schlecht
und nicht ganz gut.
Es war frisch,
aber nicht mehr windig.
Da schaut es etwas schlechter aus,
aber man hatte auch Sicht.
Die meisten Gruppen beschliessen,
in der Hütte zu bleiben,
den Sturm abzuwarten
oder direkt nach Arolla abzufahren.
Drei Gruppen brechen an diesem Morgen
Richtung Pigne d'Arolla auf.
Zuvorderst Steve House
und Simon Duverney,
gefolgt von den Ehepaaren
Barcan und Reymond.
Mario ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt immer
noch unentschlossen. Er wartet ab.
Okay.
Kurz nach 6.30 Uhr fährt auch er los.
Avanti!
Wieder hat er nicht informiert,
was der Plan ist.
Ich war mir bis am Schluss sicher,
dass wir umkehren würden.
Ich dachte, wir gehen ein Stück,
aber das wird nicht lange dauern.
(Julia)
Das Wetter kam aus der Richtung,
in die wir liefen.
Es sah nicht so schlimm aus,
insofern sagte ich auch:
"Es kommt vielleicht nicht so wild,
vielleicht kommt es gar nicht
oder es kommt später."
Ich dachte auch,
dass man ein Stück geht
und dann immer noch
entscheiden kann,
ob man nach Arolla runterfährt,
wenn es schlimm kommt
oder sich etwas ändert.
Den Moment haben wir wohl verpasst.
Mindestens zwei Faktoren hätten
in dem Moment dafür gesprochen,
die Tour abzubrechen:
der angekündigte Sturm mit Orkanböen
und Mario,
der als einziger Bergführer
allein für die grosse Gruppe
verantwortlich war.
Es ist anzunehmen,
dass er darauf spekulierte,
dass der Sturm
erst um 14 Uhr eintrifft.
Dafür spricht, dass er die Gruppe
im Verlaufe des Morgens
in der Rifugio Nacamuli abmeldet
und sich so die beiden Optionen
Cabane des Vignettes
oder Umdrehen nach Arolla offenlässt.
Darüber lässt er die Gruppe
weiterhin im Ungewissen.
(Luciano)
Vor uns befanden sich zwei Gruppen.
Sie waren vor uns.
Wir gingen
mehr oder weniger zusammen.
Mit uns
sind noch zwei andere Gruppen
zur Pigne d'Arolla hochgestiegen:
eine etwas grössere
und eine weitere, mit drei
oder vier Leuten, und dann wir.
Und wir sind alle
innerhalb von 15 Min.
am Fuss der Serpentine angekommen.
Anhand der ausgewerteten GPS-Daten
der Gruppen
lässt sich genau rekonstruieren,
wer an diesem Tag wo und
zu welchem Zeitpunkt unterwegs ist.
Gegen 9 Uhr kommen alle drei Gruppen
mehr oder weniger gemeinsam
unter der Serpentine an,
wo eine Umkehr ohne Gefahr
noch möglich gewesen wäre.
Und so sieht es zu dem Zeitpunkt
unter der Serpentine aus.
Aufnahmen aus der Gruppe
von Steve House.
Man konnte sehen,
dass der Sturm aufzieht.
Die Wolken drückten herein,
es wurde immer windiger,
es lag Feuchtigkeit in der Luft.
Es war nicht mehr trocken und klar.
Es gab keinen Zweifel mehr darüber,
was nun wirklich passiert.
Im Hintergrund erkennbar:
die Gruppe von Mario.
(Luciano) Als wir dann
unterhalb der Serpentine ankamen,
gab es andere Gruppen,
die bereits dort oben waren.
Es gab Spuren,
wir sind ihnen gefolgt.
Steve House und die Ehepaare Barcan
und Reymond sind schon unterwegs,
als Mario 10 bis 20 Min. später
beschliesst,
über die Serpentine aufzusteigen.
Er entscheidet sich damit
gegen einen Abstieg nach Arolla
und gleichzeitig
für den Weg zur Cabane des Vignettes,
dem aufkommenden Sturm entgegen.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Tommaso nimmt diesmal
bei besten Bedingungen
die Serpentine in Angriff.
Die Serpentine ist das Nadelöhr
auf dem Weg zur Pigne d'Arolla:
40 Grad steil und 300 m senkrecht
gegen Arolla abfallend.
Am Tag des Unglücks
ist sie zudem vereist
und entsprechend anspruchsvoll.
Mario muss zu dem Zeitpunkt
bewusst gewesen sein,
dass eine Umkehr unter diesen
Bedingungen praktisch unmöglich wird.
Und nun gibt es nur noch einen Weg:
über die grosse Fläche
des Col du Brenay in über 3'000 m,
im Sturm.
(Tommaso)
Ich sehe das zum ersten Mal.
Stell dir vor, du bist hier
in einem kompletten Whiteout,
du siehst nichts.
Wie soll man da wissen,
wohin man genau hingehen soll?
Originalaufnahmen von Steve House,
an derselben Stelle.
(Mann) Over there.
- (Steve House) When we go there ...
Der Sturm ist fast 4 Std. früher
hereingebrochen als prognostiziert.
Very good, there we go.
Whoo!
Hier ist es genau 9 Uhr früh,
und das ist genau 52 Min. später.
Eine grosse Veränderung
in sehr kurzer Zeit -
von blauem Himmel und etwas Wind
zu einem richtigen Sturm.
Im Hintergrund die beiden Ehepaare
Barcan und Reymond.
Auf dem Plateau ging es heftig los.
- Es war eine wirkliche Föhnmauer.
(Frau) Wir zogen die Steigeisen aus,
die Ski an und waren schon im Nebel.
(Nathalie Reymond)
Der Nebel kam sehr schnell.
10 m, es war Wahnsinn.
Der Nebel schloss uns ein.
Ich weiss,
dass ich hochschaute und dachte:
"Mist,
man sieht überhaupt nichts mehr."
Als wir weiter gingen,
waren sämtliche Spuren
vom Wind weggeblasen.
Aufnahmen der Webcam aus Arolla
in Richtung Pigne d'Arolla:
Der Föhnsturm aus Süden setzt
statt wie vorausgesagt um 14 Uhr
bereits um 10 Uhr ein.
Auch auf dem Radarbild
von Meteo Schweiz ist erkennbar,
wie sich um 10 Uhr eine erste Welle
aufbaut und dann gegen 14 Uhr,
wie erwartet, der grosse Sturm
mit voller Wucht hereinbricht.
Die Wolken wurden dichter.
Wir liefen direkt
in den Sturm hinein.
Nun gab es keinen Zweifel mehr,
was mit dem Wetter passiert.
Ich fühlte mich ziemlich sicher,
weil ich 14 Std. vorher
dort oben war
und den GPS-Track hatte
und das Gelände kannte.
Das machte es
für unsere Gruppe einfacher
und gab mir als Bergführer
Sicherheit, weil ich genau wusste,
wo ich war und wohin ich lief.
Als Mario auf dem Plateau ankommt,
herrschen bereits Windge-
schwindigkeiten von bis zu 80 km/h
Wir konnten nichts sehen.
Deshalb haben wir uns verirrt.
Ich hatte so etwas noch nie gesehen.
Ich sah, wie Mario
in irgendeine Richtung ging,
das war schon am Anfang.
Stop!
Dann hielt er an und schaute auf die
Karte und auf sein Mobiltelefon.
Mario hat auf seinem Mobiltelefon
die Route gespeichert,
doch es scheint
nicht zu funktionieren.
(Tommaso)
Ich ging zu ihm und sagte:
"Ich habe ein gutes GPS
mit gespeicherten Karten."
"Warum benützen wir es nicht? Dann
wissen wir sicher, wo wir sind."
Doch er sagte:
"Nein, ich komme klar."
Avanti!
Mario will keine Hilfe.
Noch vertraut er wohl auf seine
Erfahrung und das Satellitentelefon,
das er zur Sicherheit
auch noch bei sich hat.
Dann fing eine Phase
des andauernden Gehens an.
Im Nachhinein, wo ich darüber rede,
mir darüber Gedanken mache,
kriege ich Teile dieser Phase
nicht mehr zusammen.
Anhand der aufgezeichneten GPS-Daten
von Tommaso ist es möglich,
zu rekonstruieren, was sich
in den nächsten 24 Std. ereignet.
Man erkennt, wie die Gruppe
für die nächsten 6 Std.
in über 3'000 m
auf dem Cold du Brenay herumirrt.
Anstatt direkt
zur Pigne d'Arolla aufzusteigen,
laufen die zehn Alpinisten von
Beginn weg in die falsche Richtung.
Im Gegensatz zu Steve House:
Er folgt seinen GPS-Daten
und erreicht auf direktem Weg
um 10.37 Uhr
den Sattel der Pigne d'Arolla.
(Steve House)
Es wurde immer schlimmer.
Wir sind höher.
Man sieht, wie die Haare
vom Frost weiss werden.
Alle tragen ihre Skibrillen,
sind in Gore-Tex eingehüllt.
Und da geht es runter.
Hättest du auf dem Col du Brenay
mit all deiner Erfahrung
den Weg ohne GPS gefunden?
Ohne GPS hätte ich es
gar nicht erst versucht.
Ohne GPS hätte ich
diese Traversierung nie gemacht.
Vielleicht hätte es geklappt,
aber dabei hätte man sich
auf das Glück verlassen müssen,
und das ist nicht mein Ansatz.
Gleichzeitig sucht Mario mit seiner
Gruppe ohne GPS den Weg im Sturm.
Per Zufall treffen sie
auf die Ehepaare Barcan und Reymond,
die versuchen, sich mit Karte
und Kompass zu orientieren.
Als wir auf die Franzosen trafen,
war es dann eher so, dass Mario
und die Franzosen geredet haben.
Dass sie offensichtlich
auch wissen wollten, wo lang,
also wo es hingeht.
Dass man dann in der Hoffnung ...
In dem Moment
hoffte ich als Gruppenmitglied,
dass sie sich austauschen,
dass beide sich auskennen
und dass sie eine gute Entscheidung
treffen werden.
Là-bas!
- No, da quella parte!
(Philippe Reymond)
Wir diskutierten,
in welche Richtung
wir gehen sollten.
Mario hatte
sein Satellitentelefon dabei.
Er sagte:
"Ich denke, es geht da lang."
Ich sah das anders.
(Françoise Barcan)
Du hattest deinen Kompass.
(Philippe Reymond)
Den Kompass und die Karte.
Wir hatten
völlig andere Vorstellungen.
Ganz andere Vorstellungen.
Ich war völlig überrascht
und wollte ihm zuerst nicht folgen.
Et puis, après ...
- Es war wegen Marios Frau,
die Letzte in der Gruppe, Kalina.
Sie gab den Ausschlag.
Wir waren unentschlossen.
Da sagte sie uns:
"Der Bergführer
kennt den Weg auswendig."
"Er muss sich bloss orientieren,
dann findet er die Richtung."
"Ihr braucht euch
keine Sorgen zu machen."
Nathalie und ich sahen uns an
und fanden, dass es besser ist,
zu vierzehnt als zu viert
verloren zu gehen.
Là-bas!
(Julia) Akustisch war
kaum zu verstehen, was sie sagten.
Man sah, dass einer
in die eine Richtung zeigte
und Mario eine andere Lösung hatte.
Das war ein Moment,
wo ich auch dachte:
"Oh, das ist natürlich
auch interessant,
wenn wir uns hier schon nicht mehr
einig sind, wo es lang geht."
Es ist dieser Satz von Kalina,
der die beiden Ehepaare dazu bewegt,
Mario zu folgen,
obwohl Thierry und Philippe
immer noch nicht überzeugt sind.
Wir hatten unsere Zweifel.
Schon kurz danach
bin ich zu ihm hin und sagte:
"Das kann unmöglich stimmen."
Ich glaube, Mario
hatte ähnliche Gefühle wie wir.
"Diese Franzosen da ..."
(Nathalie Reymond)
Du hast uns gesagt, er war genervt.
"Diese vier Franzosen da,
die uns folgen,
sind nicht meine Kunden."
Das führte zu Spannungen.
Plötzlich ist Mario
als einziger Bergführer
für 14 Personen verantwortlich
im Whiteout.
Zur gleichen Zeit
erreicht Steve House
wie geplant die Cabane des Vignettes.
(Steve House)
Es ist nun 11.26 Uhr.
* Applaus *
Das ist eine kleine Feier
im Schuhraum.
Sie applaudieren den Bergführern.
Die Anspannung fällt ab.
- Genau.
Es war hart.
Man sieht den Leuten
die Erleichterung an.
Es war ein Abenteuer.
- Ja, es war ein Abenteuer.
... move further away ...
Mein Gefühl der Erleichterung
war wohl noch stärker
als bei den anderen.
Ich war zu oft
in solchen Situationen
und weiss, wie schnell
so etwas schieflaufen kann
und man
auf der falschen Seite endet.
Es ist oft ein sehr schmaler Grat.
Und wenn du auf der falschen Seite
bist, geht es um Leben und Tod.
Wie erwartet
nimmt der Sturm immer mehr zu.
Aufnahmen von Steve House
bei der Cabane des Vignettes,
als sie die Ski
in den Skiraum bringen wollen.
Mario entscheidet
ab einem gewissen Punkt,
die Ski aufzubinden
und auf Steigeisen weiterzugehen,
sodass er eine bessere Kontrolle
über die grosse Gruppe hat
und die Teilnehmenden
im Sturm einen besseren Halt.
Mario hatte
ein rotes Seil im Rucksack.
Er band sich das Seil an
und warf es uns zu.
Kalina ging am Ende und jeder hatte
das Seil stets in seiner Nähe.
(Julia) Wir waren nicht angeseilt,
sondern er band es sich um
und zog ein langes Stück Seil
hinter sich her.
Das hat wirklich geholfen,
weil es ein Orientierungspunkt
in diesem Whiteout war -
Schnee unten, Schnee oben,
weisse Wolken, Sturm.
Man konnte dem Seil folgen,
das hat sehr geholfen.
Immer wieder versucht Mario,
sein Mobiltelefon zu aktivieren,
doch es funktioniert nicht.
Nun greift er
auf das GPS von Tommaso zurück.
Tommaso, cosa dice il tuo GPS?
(Tommaso)
Und dann, nach einer halben Stunde
kam er zu mir und sagte:
"Lass mich mal schauen."
(Julia) Irgendwann
kam es dann auch zu einem Disput,
zu einer Diskussion, wo lang,
aber auch wer recht hat
oder wer die Gruppe führt.
Das fand ich
in der Situation nicht schön,
weil es mir natürlich lieber ist,
ich habe Vertrauen in eine Person
und weiss, dass sie hier
schon sehr oft lang gegangen ist.
Wer hatte in dem Moment die Führung?
Du oder Mario?
Oder habt ihr zusammengearbeitet?
Nein, ich hielt das GPS.
Mario war da, manchmal ging er weg.
Dann sagte ich: "Mario, komm zurück.
Der Track ist hier."
Das tat er dann.
Ich weiss nicht,
er suchte nach etwas.
Dann sagte ich:
"Der Track ist hier."
Fakt ist: Mario verliert damit
einen wichtigen Teil
seiner Kontrolle als Bergführer
über die Gruppe.
Seit dem Aufbruch am Morgen sind sie
nun bereits über 6 Std. unterwegs.
(Julia) Das war immer
in diesem weissen Sturm,
viel Wind, viel Schnee.
Man sah nicht so genau -
vielleicht auch zum Glück -,
was unter einem war.
Aber man wusste auch nicht,
wo man hingeht.
In einem Moment
wurde ich auch ärgerlich
und wollte mehr Erklärungen.
Ich sagte dann auch zu Kalina:
"Was machen wir hier eigentlich?
Wo sind wir?"
Ich hatte wirklich Angst.
Da kam aber eine Antwort, die mich
sehr beruhigte - Kalina sagte:
"Das ist jetzt nicht der Moment
zu diskutieren oder zu streiten,
wir machen das heute Abend
auf der Hütte im Debriefing."
Da habe ich mich aufgehoben gefühlt
und habe gesagt:
"Ja, sie recht, wir müssen jetzt
nicht hier ausflippen,
sondern heute Abend
in der Hütte ..."
Und weiterziehen.
Weitermachen und schauen,
dass wir ankommen.
Gegen 13 Uhr kommen sie
in den Bereich der Pigne d'Arolla.
Sie sind auf dem richtigen Weg.
Und dann das: ein GPS-Loch.
Hier ist unklar, was geschehen ist.
Gegen 14.30 Uhr tauchen sie plötzlich
unter dieser Felsformation auf.
Wenn ich mir als Bergführer
den Col du Brenay anschaue,
ist es hier sehr verwirrend.
Das Gelände
fällt nach allen Seiten ab,
da ist es sehr flach.
In diesem kleinen Bereich
ist es sehr leicht,
in einem Whiteout verloren zu gehen.
Du gehst im Kreis
und verlierst dabei
komplett die Orientierung.
Auch der Netzempfang auf dem
Col du Brenay ist sehr schlecht.
Zudem hat Mario anscheinend keine
Ersatzbatterien für sein Handy dabei,
auch kein funktionierendes GPS.
Auch kein Gerät,
mit dem ein Notsignal über Satelliten
hätte abgesetzt werden können
Nach über 6 Std. Herumirren
erreichen sie um 16.54 Uhr
den Sattel der Pigne d'Arolla.
Da kamen wir erst nach 6 Std. an?
- Ja, vermutlich.
Im Gegensatz dazu Tommaso jetzt.
Er benötigt 45 Min.,
um den Gletscher zu überqueren.
Ist das das Matterhorn?
- Ja.
Erstaunlich, schau dir das an!
Dann der erste Hoffnungsschimmer
für die Gruppe.
(Luciano) Als wir am Ende
des Col du Brenay ankamen,
konnte man
ein Stück des Abstiegs sehen.
Wir gingen davon aus,
dass wir es schaffen würden.
Da war die Passage,
dann sind wir da.
Wir waren sehr zuversichtlich.
Mario!
* Unverständliche Szene *
Und Tommaso erkennt auf seinem GPS
die Hütte,
sie sind auf dem richtigen Weg.
(Luciano)
Wenn einem die Kraft fehlt,
muss man sie irgendwo finden.
In solchen Situationen steckt
viel Energie im menschlichen Körper.
Auch wenn man erschöpft ist,
geht man weiter,
um sein Leben zu retten.
Ohne Pause, ohne Trinken
und Essen gehen sie weiter.
Es bilden sich zwei Gruppen:
die Stärkeren vorne,
hinten Kalina mit den Schwächeren.
Zudem hat eine Teilnehmerin
ihren Klettergurt verloren,
und Kalina
muss einen ihrer Ski tragen.
Gegen 17.50 Uhr dann
ein weiterer Hoffnungsschimmer:
Sie erreichen die Steinmännchen, den
Durchgang zur Cabane des Vignettes.
(Julia)
Ich erinnere mich sehr gut,
als wir dann
diese Steinmännchen erreichten.
Das war auch wieder so ein Moment:
"Jetzt ist es nicht mehr weit,
wir haben den richtigen Durchgang."
"Wir sind fast da."
Das machte einem wieder Mut,
dass es klappt,
dass wir fast angekommen sind.
Tommaso kommt bei besten Ver-
hältnissen bei den Steinmännchen an.
Gerade 550 m
von der rettenden Hütte entfernt.
Es ist das Nadelöhr
auf dem Weg zur Cabane des Vignettes.
Die Steinmännchen kennzeichnen
den Durchgang der Originalroute
zur Hütte, die den Hang
über den Gletscher quert
und dann durch eine Felsscharte
zur Cabane des Vignettes führt.
Als Marios Gruppe hier eintrifft,
sind sie bereits völlig entkräftet.
I just want to go there.
Das ist wahrscheinlich der Stein,
wo ich die Nacht so verbracht habe.
Ich bin etwas schockiert.
Ich habe das erwartet.
Da ist der Ort,
an dem ich den schlimmsten Moment
meines Lebens verbrachte.
Bindeglied zwischen der Hütte
und dem Ort des Dramas
ist dieser in der Luft gespannte
Wasserschlauch,
der über den
steil abfallenden Gletscher
unterhalb der Originalroute
und den Steinmännchen führt.
(Luciano)
Plötzlich sah ich die Wasserleitung,
die die Felsen
mit der Hütte verbindet.
* Unverständliche Szene *
(Tommaso)
Wir waren oberhalb der Wasserleitung
und hätten eigentlich
unterhalb sein sollen.
(Luciano) Ich sagte:
"Ich gehe hinunter zum Rohr."
Aber ich wusste nicht,
wo die Hütte war.
Das Rohr war sehr lang,
etwa 200 m lang.
Un tubo lunghissimo.
Ich wusste nicht,
ob die Hütte hier oder dort war.
Inzwischen sind Luciano und Tommaso
vor Mario, der ihnen langsam folgt.
Ich dachte: "Das ist doch toll,
hier ist irgendwo Zivilisation,
wir sind in der Nähe der Hütte.
Wir sind richtig."
(Tommaso)
Wir folgten der Wasserleitung
und stiessen
auf eine sehr steile Stelle.
Es waren fast senkrechte Séracs
aus Eis und Felsen.
Ich sagte:
"Wir können hier nicht runtergehen."
È un errore. È pericoloso.
Wir entschieden, umzudrehen.
Mario entschied, umzudrehen.
Er sagte: "Wir gehen zurück."
Wir drehten dort um und gingen
wieder zu den Steinmännchen zurück.
Ich kämpfte wirklich
mit meinen Kräften.
Eigentlich wären sie
auf dem richtigen Weg gewesen,
aber das Ende des Wasserkabels
hing durch und führte ins Steilstück.
Im Sturm konnten sie den weiteren
Verlauf des Wasserschlauchs
zur Hütte nicht erkennen.
Mario hat seine Brille verloren,
ist schneeblind.
Der Sturm tobt inzwischen
mit über 120 km/h.
Wir gingen zurück
zu den Steinmännchen,
wo wir auf die Franzosen trafen.
Sie schlugen vor,
den Gletscher hinunterzugehen.
Die Franzosen erinnern sich,
dass es neben der Originalroute
einen zweiten Weg gibt.
(Philippe Reymond)
Ich erinnerte mich vage
an einen anderen Zugang zur Hütte,
der unten rum führte.
Ich muss es
auf einer Karte gesehen haben.
Mit Tom beschlossen wir,
den steilen Abhang unter den
Steinmännchen hinunterzugehen,
um den steilen Weg links zu umgehen
und zur Hütte zu gelangen.
Der Abstieg ist auch auf dem GPS
von Tommaso erkennbar.
Da quella parte!
Sie beschliessen gemeinsam mit Mario,
noch einmal abzusteigen.
Die Gruppe folgt ihnen.
(Julia) Ich wusste -
ohne auf die Uhr zu schauen -,
dass der Tag langsam endete.
Es war langsam Zeit, anzukommen.
Vielleicht 50 m entfernt
zeichnete sich eine graue Masse
im grauen Nebel ab.
Ich hielt sie für Séracs
und sagte mir:
"Dahin darfst du nicht gehen."
(Françoise Barcan)
Das ist gefährlich.
Et c'est à ce moment que ...
Mein Höhenmesser
zeigte dann auch an,
dass wir im Verhältnis zur Hütte
zu tief waren.
Da schrie Mario: "Nein, ihr seid zu
tief, ihr müsst wieder aufsteigen."
Da gab er klare Anweisungen.
- Sehr klare Anweisungen.
Tommaso hat auf seinem GPS
nur die Sommerroute installiert,
die sich zwar nur unwesentlich
von der Winterroute unterscheidet.
Dies führt aber im Sturm dazu,
dass sie die Orientierung
definitiv verlieren.
(Tommaso) Ich hatte auf dem GPS
die Karte, die runterführte,
aber da unten war nichts.
Keine rote Linie,
die einen Weg anzeigt.
Der Weg war oben eingezeichnet,
aber wir konnten ihn nicht finden.
È troppo pericoloso.
(Luciano) Dann sagte Mario,
wir sollen wieder aufsteigen.
Am Ende gab mir Mario
das rote Seil und sagte:
"Geh du hoch. Ich bleibe hier und
helfe den anderen beim Aufstieg."
Wir brauchten dann fast eine Stunde,
um 100 m hochzuklettern.
Wir waren alle müde.
Und wieder wären sie
auf dem richtigen Weg gewesen.
Da ging es mir dann wirklich nur
noch ... fast schon ums Überleben.
Mitkommen, nicht aufgeben,
nicht schlapp machen.
"Irgendeinen Sinn wird es haben,
hier wieder hoch zu gehen."
"Sie haben gesehen,
dass es der falsche Weg war."
Dann gingen wir
das ganze Stück wieder hoch.
Für einige der Italiener
war es hart.
Sie haben dort
viel Energie verloren.
Es ist inzwischen 19.30 Uhr.
Der Sturm erreicht seinen Höhepunkt
mit Böenspitzen
von weit über 150 km/h.
Die Temperatur im Sturm
liegt weit unter Ð20 °C.
Alle sind komplett erschöpft
nach über 12 Std.
ohne richtige Pause und Essen.
(Luciano) Als ich dort ankam,
war der Wind unglaublich stark,
schlimmer noch als vorher.
Ich lief auf Knien,
um nicht umgestossen zu werden.
Irgendwann kam Mario und sagte:
"Jetzt reicht's."
"Wir warten jetzt auf Gabriella,
damit wir alle zusammen sind."
Dann sagte er: "Wir bleiben hier
und machen ein Biwak."
Es war ganz klar,
das hatte Mario auch schon gesagt,
dass wir dort bleiben.
Ich sagte zu Mario:
"Wenn wir hier bleiben,
sind wir alle tot."
Mario meinte:
"Die anderen können nicht mehr."
"Wir müssen versuchen,
uns einzugraben,
etwas Schutz zu finden ...
... und uns zu retten."
Wir haben versucht,
uns eng zusammen zu gruppieren,
um Wind abzuwehren, Wärme zu halten.
Wir waren aufgereiht -
sitzend, halb liegend aufeinander.
Vor mir, zum Teil auch
auf meinen Beinen lag Gabriella.
Es gab einen grossen Felsen
und wir dachten,
er würde uns vor dem Wind schützen.
Andrea und ich versuchten,
mit der Axt ein Loch zu graben,
aber es war sehr hart.
Wir konnten ungefähr so tief graben.
Ich bin körperlich
nicht für eine solche Kälte gemacht.
Ich habe
schon nach 10 Min. gezittert.
Auch Mario
zitterte im ganzen Gesicht.
Alle waren erschöpft.
Er war völlig erledigt,
am Boden zerstört ...
Ich ging zu ihm und sagte:
"Mario, wir versuchten, ein Loch
zu graben, aber es geht nicht."
"Ein paar Leute sind
in einem sehr schlechten Zustand."
"Es ist wichtig, ein Loch zu graben,
sonst überleben wir nicht."
Non vedo nulla.
Und seine Antwort war: "Ich kann
nichts tun. Ich sehe nichts."
Er war blind.
Mario war völlig am Ende.
Ich habe Mario noch nie so gesehen.
Mario wollte dort biwakieren,
dort war es aber zu gefährlich.
Ich sagte ihm:
"Ein Biwak hier geht nicht."
Es war sehr windig.
Unter diesen Umständen sagten wir:
"Wir müssen einen Ort
für ein Biwak finden."
Sie haben genug Kraft,
um 30 m aufzusteigen
und Schutz
hinter einem Felsen zu suchen.
(Nathalie Reymond)
Wir waren ein wenig geschützt.
(Thierry Barcan)
Wir fanden etwas Schutz.
Wir waren etwas besser geschützt.
Wir haben unter einem Felsen
Eisblöcke
und harten Schnee ausgegraben
und seitlich damit
eine kleine Mauer gebaut,
um den Wind aufzuhalten.
Ihr habt versucht,
mit den Ski und den Rucksäcken
einen Windschutz einzurichten.
(Thierry Barcan)
Die Ski haben nicht gehalten.
Ihr habt gesagt,
wir sollen uns im Loch verstecken.
Alles ist weggeflogen Ð
die Ski, Nathalies Rucksack, alles.
Ich fragte dich,
ob wir sterben würden.
Du sagtest:
"Nein, das werden wir nicht."
Und ich vertraute dir.
Das hatte ich immer
im Kopf behalten.
Während sie etwas Schutz finden,
ist die Gruppe von Mario dem Sturm,
der die ganze Nacht tobt,
voll ausgeliefert.
Ich habe mich noch
mit Andrea unterhalten, er war nah.
Ich habe versucht,
auch Andrea wach zu halten.
Ich habe noch
dieses Mittagsbrötchen rausgeholt.
Man konnte es kaum noch essen,
weil es so trocken war.
Ich teilte mir das Brötchen
mit Andrea.
Ich bekam meine Wasserflasche
nicht auf,
weil alles rutschte,
vereist und kalt war.
Meine Hände hatten keine Kraft mehr,
ich konnte sie nicht halten.
Andrea,
non riesco ad aprire la bottiglia.
Dann reichte mir Andrea
seine Flasche.
Da war es wirklich noch so:
"Hey, wir müssen uns wach halten,
wir müssen irgendetwas machen."
"Wir werden ganz sicher
nicht verzweifeln."
Zu sagen, dass ich keine Angst
gehabt hatte, zu sterben,
wäre übertrieben, aber ich hatte
keine grosse Angst zu sterben.
Vielleicht bin ich einfach positiv
und dachte:
"Das muss schon werden,
es wird irgendwie."
Man verliert ja auch
ein bisschen das Zeitgefühl.
Vielleicht war es auch
schon viel später
und wir kommen doch
gut durch die Nacht.
* Schlottern *
(Tommaso)
Du darfst nicht einschlafen.
Ich sass also da
und machte diese Bewegung.
Ich fasste einen Plan:
Für die nächsten 8 Std.
muss ich diese Bewegung machen.
Es gibt nichts anderes.
Ich muss überleben.
Es ist der einzige Weg,
um zu überleben.
Das rief ich auch Betty zu:
"Betty, du darfst
unter keinen Umständen einschlafen."
"Komm und setz dich zu mir."
Sie rief: "Ich kann nicht."
Wie von Sinnen
rief sie nur noch meinen Namen.
Betty!
Betty, non devi addormentarti!
(Luciano) Tommaso war vor mir
und ich sah,
wie er sich manchmal bewegte.
Luciano!
- Cosa vuoi, Tommaso?
Dammi la tua bottiglia!
Plötzlich kam er auf mich zu
und schlug mit den Fäusten
auf mich ein.
Er sagte: "Was mache ich bloss?"
Er war schon ein wenig weggetreten.
Er suchte etwas.
Doch was hätte ich ihm geben können?
Der Atem erzeugte Eisbärte,
die 30 cm lang waren.
Man konnte sie ab und zu abbrechen.
Es war wie in einem Zombiefilm.
Es war wie ein Mantra,
das du immer wiederholt hast:
"Wir schlafen nicht ein,
wir bewegen Finger und Füsse."
wir müssen Wärme erzeugen."
Die Ehepaare Barcan und Reymond
hatten sich in der
Cabane des Vignettes angemeldet
und hätte so eigentlich
gerettet werden können.
(Françoise Barcan)
Beim Einbruch der Nacht dachte ich,
dass sich vielleicht jemand
in der Hütte Sorgen machen würde.
Dann habe ich nicht mehr
darüber nachgedacht.
(Steve House) Die Frage war:
"Eine Gruppe hat reserviert,
aber sie ist nicht da. Wo sind sie?"
Es gibt darauf keine Antwort.
Keine festen Regeln,
kein richtiges Protokoll.
Wenn ich mich als Bergführer
bei einer Hütte angemeldet habe,
aber nicht hingehen kann,
rufe ich den Hüttenwart an,
weil ich weiss,
dass er das nachverfolgt.
Aber ich denke,
viele Gruppen tun das eben nicht.
Und das ist dann eben
so ein Graubereich,
wo man nicht weiss,
wer kommt und wer nicht.
Das geschieht öfter.
Leute haben reserviert
und kommen nicht.
Der Hüttenwart hat uns dann erklärt,
warum er sich tatsächlich
keine Sorgen
über unsere Abwesenheit gemacht hat.
Er hat so viele
unangekündigte Absagen,
dass er nicht jedes Mal
die Rettungskräfte rufen kann,
wenn die Leute nicht kommen.
Die Leute reservieren
und kommen nicht.
Die Leute kommen nicht.
Darum.
Es gibt einfach
zu viele solche Vorfälle.
Sie sagen einfach nicht ab.
Wenn ich nur gewusst hätte,
dass da draussen Menschen sind,
dann hätte ich Simon gepackt
und versucht, sie zu erreichen.
Wir sind starke Alpinisten.
Aber wir wussten wirklich nicht,
dass sie da waren.
Ich fühle mich deswegen
sehr schlecht.
Hätte ich es gewusst,
wäre es keine Frage gewesen,
dass wir es
wenigsten versucht hätten.
Mario hat seine Gruppe
nie in der Hütte angemeldet.
Niemand weiss, dass sie nur 550 m
davon entfernt um ihr Leben kämpfen.
Irgendwann, mitten in der Nacht,
rafft sich Mario mit letzter Kraft
doch noch einmal auf.
(Julia) Er kam irgendwann zu mir
und setzte sich
zu meiner rechten Seite.
Und da sagte ich:
"Mario, was ist jetzt
mit dem Satellitentelefon?"
"Lass uns dieses Satellitentelefon
endlich mal benutzen."
Und dann holten wir Marios
Satellitentelefon aus dem Rucksack,
und es hat auch geleuchtet.
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere,
leuchtete es rot und grün.
Er hat es also benutzt,
er hat es ganz sicher benutzt.
Ich sagte ihm: "Lass es uns
ausprobieren. Mach was, tu was!"
Er hatte es dabei.
Es war geladen.
Aber es funktionierte nicht.
Und irgendwann stand er auf
und war weg.
Danach habe ich ihn
auch nicht mehr gesehen.
Ab diesem Zeitpunkt
wurde es immer ruhiger.
Ich dachte an meine Mutter
und meine Frau und sagte mir:
"Das verdienen sie nicht."
"Ich muss am Leben bleiben.
Es geht nicht allein um mich."
Na ja, ich dachte dann schon
irgendwann:
"Oh Gott, sind jetzt alle tot?"
Sind sie einfach eingeschlafen?
Schlafen sie?
Und Gabriella
wurde dann immer stiller.
Sie lag mir auf den Beinen.
Andrea, non devi addormentarti!
Gabriella!
Gabriella.
Ich erinnere mich,
dass ich anfing zu träumen.
Ich träumte von schönen Dingen,
mir war nicht einmal mehr kalt.
Mir ging es gut.
Ich wollte nur schlafen
und das war's.
Ich träumte von
surrealen Landschaften mit Blumen
und sich drehenden Girlanden.
Ich erinnere mich an alles sehr gut.
Und dann nichts.
Nacht bis zum Krankenhaus
am Nachmittag.
Was danach geschah, wissen nur die,
die uns gerettet haben.
Was ist passiert?
Julia versucht zu verstehen,
und fliegt im Sommer
mit dem Rettungsspezialisten
Pascal Gaspoz
noch einmal zurück
zur Unfallstelle.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Siehst du dort oben
die Steinmännchen?
Da wart ihr.
Wahnsinn,
wenn man die Entfernung sieht.
Wo waren wir?
- Ihr wart da unten.
Die Franzosen waren etwas
weiter oben bei den grossen Felsen.
Es ist sehr nah.
Ja, 30 bis 40 m
Die Wind- und Wetterbedingungen
waren dort wirklich besser?
Das ist hier wie ein kleiner Pass,
wo der Wind noch beschleunigt.
Die beiden Plätze
sind sehr unterschiedlich.
Der Platz oben
ist vom Wind geschützt.
Die gefühlte Temperatur
ist im Bereich mit viel Wind
um 15 bis 20 °C tiefer.
Man hat ganz andere
Überlebenschancen.
Das kann man nicht vergleichen.
Dies ist wohl auch der Grund,
warum die Franzosen
die Nacht überlebt haben.
Es ist inzwischen 6.30 Uhr.
Der Sturm hat sich etwas gelegt,
die Wolken haben aufgerissen.
Nathalie ist die Einzige,
die am Morgen stark unterkühlt
das Bewusstsein verliert,
aber doch gerettet werden kann.
(Philippe Reymond)
Am Morgen hatten wir Glück,
dass der Wind
etwas nachgelassen hatte.
Wir hatten viel Glück.
Wenn es so weitergegangen wäre,
bei starkem Wind,
dem Föhn und dem Nebel,
wären die Helikopter nicht gekommen.
Man hätte die Hütte
auch nicht gesehen.
Dann wäre von den 14 Leuten hier
keiner mehr am Tisch.
Inzwischen macht sich
auch Steve House
in der Cabane des Vignettes bereit
für die letzte Etappe seiner Tour
nach Zermatt.
(Steve House) Das ist um 6.16 Uhr
am Morgen vom 30. April.
Als wir die Hütte verliessen,
hatte der Sturm etwas nachgelassen.
Es war okay. Wir versuchen,
nach Zermatt zu gelangen.
Das ist der erste Teil
unserer Etappe:
Simon vorne, ich am Schluss.
Wir fahren über die Ebene.
Von da an habe ich keine Fotos mehr,
weil Simon
gleich danach Mario gefunden hat.
Aufnahmen aus der Gruppe,
Sie erkennen einen Menschen.
Als Simon zu ihm aufsteigt,
realisiert er, dass Mario tot ist.
(Mann) There is a dead body.
Mario hat es geschafft,
den Weg zur Hütte einzuschlagen,
ist dann aber
vor Erschöpfung und Unterkühlung
zusammengebrochen und gestorben.
Wo war Mario?
Mario lag etwas weiter unten, unter
dem Felsband dort im Steilhang.
Es war Mario,
der zuerst gesehen wurde.
Es war also zuerst Mario und
nicht wir, die ein Zeichen gaben?
Wir wurden informiert, dass eine
Person dort unten gefunden wurde.
Es war also Mario,
den man zuerst gesehen hatte.
Dadurch wussten wir, wo ihr wart.
(Weinerlich)
Dann hat Mario uns ja doch gerettet.
Ja.
- Schön.
* Julia schluchzt. *
Als Julia am Morgen erwacht,
sind nur sie und Tommaso
noch bei Bewusstsein.
Ich öffnete meine Augen
und sah die Hütte ganz nah vor mir.
Dann sah ich unten Steve House,
der mit einer Gruppe
von Tourengängern zu mir hochstieg.
Und dann fingen wir an, zu schreien.
Ich glaube,
Tommaso hat zuerst geschrien.
Aiuto!
(Lauter) Aiuto!
(Julia) Wir hatten Glück,
dass eine Gruppe frühmorgens
losgegangen war und uns hörte.
(Mann) Steve is coming back down,
he is running towards his pack.
Do you think he is coming back here?
Steve House kehrt zur Hütte zurück,
als er das das Ausmass des Unglücks
realisiert.
Inzwischen hat der Hüttenwart die
Einsatzzentrale in Sion alarmiert.
Die Retter der Air-Glaciers
starten mit der Information,
dass eine Person
in Schwierigkeiten sei.
Beim Anflug
auf die Cabane des Vignettes
sehen wir unter dem Bergsattel
auf der Höhe der Hütte
eine Person im Schnee liegen.
Weitere Personen machen am Bergkamm
auf sich aufmerksam.
(Mann) Holy shit!
Ich frage den Piloten, ob er uns
in diesem Gebiet absetzen kann.
Ich gehe zwischen den Felsen im
Schnee hinunter und sehe die Gruppe.
Ich drehe mich um und sehe Personen,
die mit Schnee bedeckt
im Schnee liegen.
Andere Personen stehen aufrecht,
mehr oder weniger ansprechbar.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt
zeigen alle Teilnehmenden
keine sichtbaren Lebenszeichen mehr.
Sie sind stark unterkühlt
und haben schwere Erfrierungen.
Es folgt eine der grössten
Rettungsaktion in den Alpen.
Teilweise sind sieben Helikopter
im Einsatz: Air-Glaciers, Rega
und Air Zermatt
arbeiten unter Zeitdruck zusammen.
Ich entscheide, alle
möglichst schnell zur Hütte bringen,
damit das Wetter,
das immer schlechter wird,
die Rettung nicht verhindert.
Wir müssen schnell arbeiten.
14 Menschen werden in die
Cabane des Vignettes gebracht,
wo sie von den anwesenden Notärzten
versorgt und in die Walliser Spitäler
sowie nach Lausanne und Bern
geflogen werden.
Sechs von ihnen sterben im Spital.
Auch Luciano
ist nicht mehr bei Bewusstsein,
als er ins Inselspital Bern
eingeliefert wird.
Ich lag auf der Intensivstation
und war in einem schlechten Zustand.
26 °C Körpertemperatur,
5 Herzschläge, eingedicktes Blut.
Man musste
das ganze Blut austauschen.
Es war fast hoffnungslos.
Luciano hat überlebt,
wie auch Tommaso und Julia,
die beide mit leichten Erfrierungen
das Krankenhaus
wieder verlassen können.
Doch das Trauma bleibt.
(Luciano) Ich wurde im
Krankenhaus schon am nächsten Tag
von einem Psychologen betreut.
Mit ihm habe ich
alles ein wenig aufgearbeitet,
bis er mir sagte:
"Jetzt solltest du
darüber hinweg sein."
Tatsächlich habe ich mich
nicht mehr bei ihm gemeldet.
Ich bin alleine zurechtgekommen.
Für mich ist es gut gelaufen,
für die anderen nicht.
Was will man machen?
Man kann daran nichts mehr ändern.
(Tommaso)
Vieles war in den nächsten Tagen
oder sogar Jahre anders als zuvor.
Ich musste Medikamente nehmen
und war die ganze Zeit nervös.
Ja, es war schwierig.
Die Zukunft wird es zeigen.
Mit der Zeit wird man sehen.
Das Ganze
hätte nicht geschehen sollen.
Menschen sind nicht stärker
als die Natur.
Es ist dumm, sich in eine
solche Situation zu bringen.
Der Typ war dumm und
wir waren so dumm, ihm zu folgen.
(Julia) Mario war
ein verantwortungsvoller Bergführer.
Er hätte uns nie aus Leichtsinn
in eine solche Situation gebracht.
Davon bin ich überzeugt.
Vielleicht könnte man sagen,
dass er sich zu gut auskannte,
vielleicht hatte er zu viel
Vertrauen in sich selber und dachte:
"Wir schaffen das
trotz des schlechten Wetters."
"Ich weiss ja, wo es lang geht."
Diese Erklärung
könnte ich mir noch vorstellen.
Dass er sich am Ende
zu sicher fühlte.
Das Verfahren wurde von der
Staatsanwaltschaft eingestellt.
Hätte Mario überlebt,
hätte sie aufgrund
seiner Position als Bergführer
bezüglich der Straftatbestände
Körperverletzung
und fahrlässige Tötung
ermitteln müssen.
Es konnten keine Verantwortlichkeiten
von anderen Personen
festgestellt werden.
* Sanfte Musik *
War es Pech?
Menschliches Versagen?
Oder Leichtsinn?
Untertitelung: Sucevic Solutions
im Auftrag von SWISS TXT - 2023